it seems like everything is more
expensive these days but it's especially
true for one basic item right now that
most of us eat eastern
easter end passover it's called are less
than a week away and the price of eggs
have you heard has skyrocketed producers
say that there are several factors
including an outbreak of bird flu that
are driving up those costs
omar villafranca visited a texas egg
farm to see how one farmer is coping
sam miller has more than eight thousand
hungry beaks to feed every day at cedar
ridge egg farm in northeast texas but
the rising cost of the ingredients that
make the feed is forcing miller to raise
his egg prices what ingredients in this
have gone up wait for one wheat since
this has wheat yeah it's gone up and and
due to russia so a warts more than six
thousand miles away is affecting the
cost of this oh yeah how much is that
going up uh it's all anywhere from 10 to
12 percent it's up it's went up people
hear that number they don't think it's
much but don't tell me much but i may
not each every month i spend thirty
three thousand dollars in feed that bill
is up nearly seven thousand dollars a
month from what he used to pay i don't
jack my price up i make a little bit i
don't make a lot off my egg the war in
ukraine a major grain producer and
drought conditions in the u.s have
pushed grain prices up significantly
that has driven up the price of eggs by
56 percent last year the national
average for a dozen large white eggs was
a dollar sixty now it's up to two
dollars and fifty cents your morning
breakfast price is going up all the way
from the eggs but to the bacon and the
toast and everything else livestock
economist david anderson says the worst
avian flu outbreak in seven years has
killed more than 20 million birds in 24
states and has chipped away at the egg
supply and pushed prices up it takes
time to adjust to higher prices and
higher costs higher fuel prices are also
hammering miller the cost for miller to
fill up his delivery truck almost
doubled and he's doing everything he can
to avoid raising his egg prices again
you know there's going to come a point
in time where i have to do something and
i'm not going to be here for cbs
mornings omar villafranca picton texas
he's so right when he says it takes time
to adjust to higher prices especially
when it's something that you're so used
to buying yeah and paying x amount of
dollars yeah yeah i mean and with a lot
of groceries you can go to the store
brand and save some money but if you're
already at the store brand you're
throwing you're taking stuff out of the
cart that's right you're in trouble